state of Montana has become the first to
actually ban the app Montana's
Republican Governor Greg gianforte
signed a bill outlawing tick tock's use
in his State he is the first state to do
so Governor Jan Forte said yesterday the
law is meant to protect Montana's
personal data from falling into the
hands of the Chinese government
something Tick-Tock claims has never
happened the Lopper hope it's apt stores
from allowing downloads of tick tock
within Montana's borders industry trade
group TechNet says app stores don't
currently have the ability to block
downloads on a state-by-state basis
Montana's government says Tick-Tock as
well as the Google and apple run app
stores could face penalties of ten
thousand dollars per violation as well
as another 10 000 for each day that
violation continues Tick Tock says the
State's new law violates its users First
Amendment rights and argues the video
app empowers hundreds of thousands of
people throughout the state